is it true there's a story that you and
I don't know if it's true it might just
be a rumor that once you Marlon Brando
and I think John Travolta were together
in Mexico City together and you had to
get out of Mexico City and you needed a
plane ride and John Travolta figured it
out is that true yeah well that's all
the time
can you tell us about that I just love
hearing I mean first of all any Brando
story I have to hear it well we had so
we had a project about how do I talk
fast we had a project mhm
Marlon and I had a project that we
really wanted to do the screenplay had
been written but we didn't own the
rights to the book it was written based
on it was the kind of spec screenplay so
we had to go down and try to convince
the writer of that book who was Gabriel
Garcia Marquez yeah to read this script
and would he let us make this movie and
it was a great role from Marlon and we
got down there and found and we wanted
to go secretly because he had already
told me no and so we wanted to just show
up at his door but Marlon wanted to you
know sort of as men of the same
generation right ask him to do it so we
get to Mexico he'd gotten somebody to
get Marlon what a studio set gave us a
plane to get down there but it was
supposed to take us down do the meeting
and come back we got down there and
Marquez wasn't in town so we we got him
on the phone he agreed to meet with
Marlon but he was gonna be back in five
days so we're in this owner Rossa at our
hotel was under us and we we said to
send a plane back by the time we were
ready to leave we'd had such a it was
such a fun trip yeah a couple of other
producer Michael Fitzgerald and another
fella and we were down you know holed up
in this room and we didn't want to break
this spell of the time that we'd had
which which ended in Marquez agreeing we
were never able to make the film for
ridiculous reasons about insurance in
Marlon
but it was a great time when we didn't
want to break that spell and we were
thinking gosh it would be yeah it'd be
great to have another private jet but
going to an airport with Marlon was a
whole thing you know the Godfather so I
I said to him I said you know I said cuz
John Travolta had mentioned to me you
know I really love to meet Marlon at
some point and I said did more than I
said what do you think of John Travolta
he's got his own plane so I tracked down
John on the set of primary colors I'm in
Mexico City he's over here in Culver
City and he was just rapping for the day
and I said hey you want to meet Marlon
right he was down there two or
two-and-a-half hours later and we all
just spent the night laughing I'm
playing chess and telling stories and
then everybody crashed and got up the
next day and got on the plane and on
John's plane and he flew down there but
he had a pilot with him so he hung out
in the back with us and took more
stories until we landed here I'm glad he
had a pilot with him because if he hung
out in the back with you guys especially
if it's a Boeing yes
no please they're a big sponsor you'll
never be back